Hey everybody, how's it going? My name is Mayuko and welcome
back to my channel. So as a productivity slash lifestyle
slash career YouTuber, or whatever I am, who often talks
about navigating life and how to deal with it, I get why you
might expect me to sit here and tell you that I have life
all figured out. And that you should listen to me because I
know what I'm doing and always have, you might even think
that I have things figured out because that's just what you
assume about other people about YouTubers and quote unquote,
successful people, I get why you might think that, but
that's not me. More importantly, it's just not true. In
fact, now more than ever, I have no idea what I'm doing.
Before we continue, I wanted to say a quick thank you to
better help for sponsoring today's video. I'm actually so
excited that betterhelp is sponsoring this very video
because part of the story is about therapy and mental
health. And I think it's safe to say that I wouldn't be who
I am today in overcoming anxiety episodes and panic attacks
and stuff, without the help of a trained professional to
help me understand my mind. Better helpful, assess your
needs and match you with your own licensed professional
therapist, and you can start communicating within 48 hours.
It's not a crisis line, it's not self help. It's actually
professional counseling done securely online, there's a
really broad range of expertise in better helps 15,000 plus
counselor network, which may not be locally available in
many areas, the service is available for clients worldwide.
And you can log into your account anytime and send a message
to your counselor, you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses. Plus, you can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions. And they're committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches. So they make it easy and free to change
counselors if needed. It's actually more affordable than
traditional offline counseling and financial aid is
available better help wants you to start living a healthier
and happier life today. So make sure to go to better
help.com slash when you go. That's better H e LP, and join
the over 1 million people taking charge of their mental
health. With the help of an experienced professional,
they're actually giving a special offer for all of my
subscribers so you can get 10% off your first month at
better health.com slash my you go. Last year, I left a
career in tech to pursue becoming a content creator and
youtuber full time it's been going really well. But it's
also felt really like foreign to me in a way that I have
like trouble putting into words. So as you can probably
guess I've been spending a lot of time thinking about this
because introspection is my hobby. You see, in my old
career, whenever I would interview for a job as a software
engineer,
they would sometimes ask me something like, Where do you see
yourself in five years? And back then that was easy for me
to answer. The tech world has kind of like an established
standard job path. And things often follow the same pattern.
So I basically had three options to choose from. One was to
continue being a software engineer, the second was to become
a manager. And the third was to become like a tech lead or
an architect of some sort. And they were perfectly
legitimate careers. But I just remembered like not being
particularly excited by any of them. The best way that I
could describe it is that they were just kind of vanilla,
they weren't bad necessarily like vanilla is a perfectly
valid and good flavor of ice cream. Obviously, it was just
really standard, like kind of uninspiring to me, but their
vanilla ness didn't register to me as something that really
mattered in my decision. They were just the choices that I
was given like everybody else around me, subconsciously I
was probably yearning for something like rocky road or hot
fudge or something just like something different. But at
that point, I hadn't even realized that those things had
existed. I thought that for me, the vanillas were all I had
to choose between, honestly, ever since I declared my major
in computer science, my freshman year of college up until
like last year, it felt like I was walking down a well worn
path. I was surrounded by people just like me all walking
the same direction. All people would talk about was how they
were like a million jobs in our industry, and how things
were always growing. And deviating from that path that we
were all walking on was seen as like kind of a risky and
unconventional decision. So there were like these preset
steps on that path that everybody would follow. Like get an
internship, find a job as a junior software engineer, put
three years of work in move up to senior engineer and so on.
And I think it's only natural that like the earlier you are
in your career. The more that you're going to follow trails
like that when you're just getting started and you're
learning as you go and you're like trying to grow in your
career. It just makes sense to take others leads on those
things. So it made sense to me at the time, I always thought
that you needed to have like a goal or like a destination
for your path in life. Like, if you didn't even know where
you were gonna end up, then it wasn't even worth it to
start. So I defined my own life and career goals based on
what others had told me to do. And based on what others had
done before me, it felt like it was the right thing for me
to do, because it was the right thing for them. Of course,
it wasn't easy to do all those things like it was hard work.
But it was also just like, kind of expected. If that makes
sense. Anyone who wanted to stay in tech long term would
benefit from following these steps. That's why being a
content creator has felt weird in a lot of ways. To me,
YouTube, and creative work is just different. There are
interviews or like starter jobs to like, get a handle on
things, I guess there are technically like co workers, but
they're often just pictures on a computer screen. And you're
so alone a lot of the time, especially when you're starting
out. finding success in tech definitely requires some luck,
especially when you're finding your first job. But the path
after that just tends to be a lot more predictable. When it
comes to content creation, success always comes and goes
completely by chance. Or even accidentally, you never really
know when or why opportunities come. It feels like the
universe just randomly decides to throw them at you for
factors you will never understand. And you just kind of have
to be ready at all times. So the idea of like random luck
type success isn't super new to me. But I was surprised just
how much unpredictability and ambiguity there is in YouTube,
because there's like no roadmap or rules or anything. It's
like the Wild West like it just makes no sense. Sometimes
what I'm trying to say is none of this was like according to
plan or was part of any plan that I had. And that was all in
stark, stark contrast to my software engineering career.
Don't get me wrong, it was really exciting. But it was also
a little loose and erratic. Like the rhythms were just
different. There were fewer conventions to follow. And all
of a sudden, I just realized I was so unprepared to be a
content creator. I had no idea how difficult creative work
is, I barely took any creative classes in college, I just
never even thought to quote unquote, work on creativity or
being creative, because everything I had done was to get a
degree and career in STEM. But all of a sudden, I needed to
learn how to adapt to creative work, like learning how to
edit, set up cameras, and lending equipment and design
thumbnails. Over time, I started to feel more confident in
my initial creative skills, and I started having fun with
it. I saw the impact that I can make online,
I started to dream about the possibility of making videos
full time and leaving my job in tech. And eventually, I knew
in my heart that this is what I really wanted to do. But
coming from a job where I had things to hold on to for
safety. The thought of doing so was really scary. Like in my
old jobs, we used to have managers and supervisors that
helped us along our paths, and resources like leveling
guides that literally outline expectations for skills and
responsibilities at different career stages, step by step.
They don't have that sort of thing in content creation. No
youtuber has ever consulted a PDF about what to expect when
they hit 500,000 subscribers or whatever. So even though I
was finding a lot of fulfillment in my work in YouTube, I
just kept feeling this like really powerful feeling that
even if I gave this career job, my all, nothing was
guaranteed. Like there was no floor or safety net beneath
me. And the future was suddenly so murky, like would I still
be making YouTube videos like five years from now what even
would the landscape of like the internet and the online
world and tech even look like envisioning content creation
as a career felt like I was looking into this like deep,
dark, murky pit, so dark that I couldn't even see the bottom
of it. And all of that unknown about my life and the future,
directly fed straight into my anxiety about everything? Full
disclosure, I've had anxiety for years now. And all of these
life changes kind of just made it more intense. For years,
my instinct when I had anxiety was to just like brace
against it and fight it. And that was the natural reaction
to all of this ambiguity. But this is what I learned one of
the most valuable lessons about my anxiety. My therapist
taught me that if I fight my anxiety, it'll only come back
bigger. That concept was so difficult for me to grasp at
first. It's just so counterintuitive. Why wouldn't you fight
it like I didn't want to have anxiety. Obviously, so what
you're supposed to just like, let it flow through you and
take over and do whatever it wants. So the natural instinct
is to fight it, and I would resist it with all of my mind, I
would thrash against it. But every time the same thing would
happen, it would just get worse. My therapist compared it to
standing on the beach, as waves come at you and trying to
fight them as they crash around you. These waves are made up
of your obstacles and anxieties coming from all different
places, like work or family or your emotions. And if you try
to stand still and resist them, and especially if you try to
fight or think your way out of them, you're eventually going
to get worn down and knocked over and thrown around, like
what I'm fighting against my own brain and trying to make
sense of conflicting signals and intrusive thoughts and
nervousness and all of these things, a bunch of new notion
documents or to do lists or strategic planning sessions
aren't going to do the trick and keeping me grounded and at
peace. I understand now that it's just much easier to stop
resisting and to ride with your anxiety and the waves it
makes and just go with the flow. Ever since I tried this
approach, things have been better, it's all helped me kind
of untangle the problem. And in a lot of ways, let go, I
realized that I may not be able to make my anxiety go away
completely, or make bad things don't happen. But I can learn
to live with them. I think I just had to let go of the
instinct to hold on tightly to my plans and goals and
control things. So rigidly, I feel like you actually limit
yourself and your experiences when you're holding on so
desperately. It was like I was squeezing my eyes shut the
whole time, I had to open them to realize I wasn't even
allowing myself to live my life. My life has possibilities
that I hadn't even dreamed existed, and I couldn't even see
them. So now instead of walking around blind, I try to see
the world for what it is and not torture myself for worrying
about everything. This whole process has made me feel more
okay with ambiguity,
maybe that thing will happen. Maybe it won't, I'll be riding
the wave either way. A year ago, my goals were in one way or
the other defined by others. Now, I'm on my own. My goals
and dreams are my own and designed by me, my successes and
failures are my own. Now I understand what I want for my own
life. And my new outlook has helped me to realize that
sometimes it's just as simple as getting good sleep, having
a comfy place to call home, spending time with family, good
food, and laughter. Honestly, I would say now that I'm
probably the most me I've been in a very long time, I feel
super fortunate that I get to do exactly what I want to do
in a city that I love, and put energy into the things and
people I love most and make a living doing it. I've just
realized that life is like a big Choose Your Own Adventure
book with a million different blank pads for you to choose.
And one of the best and most fun parts of those books is the
surrender to the process. You don't totally know the
consequences of each choice. But you know, the some of them
will be compelling and will take you somewhere fulfilling.
And also, you can always look up in the middle of the book
and be like, I don't like where this adventure is going
today. Maybe I don't want to go on a jungle adventure. I
just prefer the idea of setting sail on an adventure where I
don't know what might happen, rather than setting sail for
like a normal Island kind of nearby that everybody tells me
is really nice. And they gave me the map already and stuff.
It's called charting your own course for a reason, you know,
and part of what that means is that I literally have to
chart my own path where it didn't exist before my position
as a YouTuber and the niche that I'm filling literally
didn't exist before me. I don't have a roadmap. And it is
fucking hard a lot of the time. Like I'm a 100%, self taught
content creator. I didn't even know how to work a camera a
couple years ago. But I know now that there's just so much
that I haven't experienced out in this ocean. I realized
during my short time making videos that there's just
literally so much that I had no idea even existed. But even
that feels exciting. Like I'd rather be open to the
possibilities than to turn them away. And I know that even
though it's going to be a fun adventure, that doesn't mean
that it's going to be easy, it's probably going to be more
difficult, but any struggle will still be underlined with
the fact that this is all my journey. A lot of it is just
about honoring my own feelings, which a lot of the time
means facing fear, finding a way to move on then reflecting
on what I've learned. At least that's the process I've
managed to work out so far. So instead of getting Stuck on
what scares me. I'm working to adjust my perspective, to
focus on the possibilities that this position affords me and
letting things flow from that positivity that feels more
productive than letting the difficulties hit me head on and
dwelling on them. It feels like everything has changed for
me ever since I changed my perspective to think in this way.
The world looks different and feels less intense. So I don't
know where I'm headed, or frankly, what I'm even doing a lot
of the time, but for the first time in my life, I'm okay
with that. I'm here in the dark, deep end of the ocean
without a map, and I feel good. I know it's where I should
be. Even though I still don't know what I'm doing.